Wir schauen auf die europäischen Top-Ligen und da gab es vor allem ein Thema, was dominiert hat, der Abschied von Jürgen Klopp. Aber das wird nicht das einzige sein, was wir heute besprechen mit Fabian Pakulat, Mario Rieker und Uli Hebel. Los geht's! Heute im Rasenfunk? Is magnificent!
Gamechanger.
Ich sehe schon, irgendwann muss es da mal den Stand-off zwischen euch beiden geben. Das wird dann das nächste. Irgendwie wirkt auch Uli dreimal so, als ob er was sagen wollen würde.
Ich sage auch, ich bin einmal durchgepredert.
Na gut, wir werden es uns einfach weiter verfolgen. Und dann machen wir doch einfach der Sieger dieses Spiels. Der ist dann auch der Sieger des Dues zwischen dir und Christian. Allegri Versteher, ja oder nein, das ist dann die Frage. Und so entscheiden wir das dann. Dann lasst uns noch ganz schnell zu unseren Awards kommen. Also MVP, Unsung Hero und Moment des Spieltags. Da habt ihr alle was mitgebracht. Uli, wer wäre denn dein MVP? Oder müssen wir da jetzt, wollen wir da jetzt Jürgen Klopp eintragen? Oder hast du noch was anderes?
Ja, ich weiß ja, ich komme ohne die tägliche Dosis Luten nicht aus in dieser Ligatur. Und an einem Spieltag, in dem Lutentown, Brightonhof, Albion mit 4-0 schlägt, finde ich, dass Rob Edwards den Award verdient hat. Das ist dann der Jürgen Klopp MVP Award, den dann Rob Edwards verdient. Ich glaube, dann können alle damit leben. Also sowas habe ich noch nicht gesehen. Kenny, also wer diese Szenen noch irgendwo abgreifen kann. Das war das beste Stückchen Fußball, das wahrscheinlich da je gespielt worden ist. Das ist natürlich der Klassiker, dass der Zerbi einfach so stur da reinläuft in die tiefe Verteidigung und die machen einfach genau das. Aber so musst du es erstmal vorbereiten als gegnerischer Trainer mit den Mitteln. Luthen hat echt eine Chance drin zu bleiben. Ich glaube mehr und mehr daran. Deswegen hat sich Rob Edwards diesen Award mehr als nur verdient.
Stimmt. Das waren nämlich 1 zu 0 erste Minute, 2 zu 0 dritte Minute. Das ist genau meines Wissens nach zweimal passiert an diesem Wochenende. Einmal bei diesem Spiel und dann bei Duisburg gegen Nürnberg in der Frauen-Bundesliga. Und auch da könnte der Klub dadurch drin bleiben, ist nämlich über die Abstiegsplätze hinausgesprungen.
Hetrick Adebayo ist auch wie so ein Einhorn. Der ist so lang, der ist so dürr, so richtig drahtig. Und trotzdem kann der Ballcarrier sein. Und komischerweise gibt es so viele große Spieler, die gar nicht so richtig gut Kopfball spielen können. Das ist so ein ganz aufregender Spieler. Wenn man den sieht, merkt man immer sofort, da ist was los. Nur 60 Minuten lang, weil dann ist er meistens platt. Aber echt ein aufregender Spieler. Ich sehe den sehr gerne.
Sehr gut. Adebayo werden wir uns angucken und looten. Jetzt damit eben auch aus den Abstiegsringen herausgesprungen. Aktuell 17. mit 19 Punkten. Und überhaupt sehr, sehr gute Serie. Jetzt 3 Siege, ein Unentschieden aus den letzten 5 Spielen. Da kommen 13 der 19 Punkte her. Das ist schon einigermaßen bemerkenswert. Und dann stelle ich fest, Fabian, in der La Liga wird der MVP-Award offenbar jetzt so ein Atletico-Ding, weil wir hatten das letzte Mal Antoine Griezmann. Und jetzt freust du dich mit stolzgeschwellter und freude-strahlender Brust. Eine Brust kann jetzt auf Freude strahlen, Jürgen Klopp zu nennen.
Ja, aber das ist tatsächlich so. Ich muss ihn nennen, auch wenn ihr vielleicht aus der Vergangenheit wisst, dass ich nicht sein größter Fan bin. Aber man muss ihm zugute halten, was er gerade aus Atletico Madrid macht. Ja, hört sich gerade oder schaut gerade richtig gut aus. Ich glaube, der Pokalsieg gegen Real Madrid hat die Mannschaft doch mal richtig gepusht. Wir sind im Moment Tabellen-Dritter, haben die letzten Spiele, weiß ich nicht, drei, vier Spiele gewonnen, sind in richtig guter Form. Hat ein paar gute Spieler integriert in das Team, wie zum Beispiel in Neuzugang Samuel Lino, der im Moment ganz gut funktioniert. Sogar zwei Nachwuchsspieler sind im Moment öfter in der Stadt, mit Riquelme und Pablo Varios, die ganz viel Spaß machen. Und vorne hat man halt mit Griezmann, mit Morata, mit Memphis Depay und Angel Correa auch ein ordentliches Pfund. Und im Moment muss ich ihm einfach diesen MVP geben, kann ich nichts machen.
Das aber zeichnet dich ja aus, dass es wahre Größe ist, dass du da über deinen Schatten springst. Stellt sich die Frage, was Mario bei seinem MVP machen musste. Musstest du da auch irgendwo hinspringen?
Nein, überhaupt nicht, überhaupt nicht. Meiner heißt Matteo Retegui, spielt beim Aufsteiger aus Genoa, die tatsächlich sehr viel Spaß machen. Also da mal ein kleiner Tipp, Alberto Ciladino, der ist auch was für ein M-Faktor, aber guter Trainer tatsächlich. Die spielen schön Fußball, die werden nichts mit dem Abstieg zu tun haben. Auch eben aufgrund sehr spannenden Jungstürmers, wird auch in der italienischen Nationalmannschaft sicherlich noch auf sich aufmerksam machen. Kam aus Argentinien, die Großeltern sind italienische Stadtbürger. Papa hat unter anderem für die argentinische Feldhockey-Nationalmannschaft gespielt und die Schwester auch im Feldhockey Olympische Silber geholt. Er zockt aber ganz gut Fußball, Torschützenkönig geworden mit Tigre in der Saison 21-22. Und dann ist er eben zu Genoa für 12 Millionen. Und der hat an den ersten sieben Spieltagen direkt nach dem Aufstieg, denen schon viele Punkte gebracht, drei Tore erzielt. Und dann hat er Knieprobleme gehabt und Genoa hatte auch eine richtige Durststrecke. Jetzt ist er endlich wieder zurück. Genoa seit sieben Spielen ungeschlagen, 13 Punkte geholt. Die letzten drei davon konnte er jetzt auch endlich wieder über 90 Minuten machen. Und zwei davon davor hat Genoa immer nur Remy gespielt und jetzt haben sie zweimal in Folge gewonnen. Eben auch dank Treffer von ihm. Am letzten Wochenende hat er 0-1 zu Hause gegen Lecce mit einem Tor und einer Vorlage gedreht. Und das ist so ein Unterschiedsspieler bei einem Team, das sich jetzt einpendelt zwischen als Aufsteiger, wo du in Italien eigentlich immer Abstiegskandidat Platz 20 bist, werden die sich einpendeln auf Platz 9, 10. Sogar mit Schlagdistanz theoretisch auf, wenn es einen OE-Cup geben würde, die Richtung. Aber ich finde, das ist ganz bemerkenswert und der macht richtig Spaß. Also guck den gerne mal an.
Stark. Sehr gut. Ach, ich liebe diese Kategorie. Uli, wer ist dein Unsung-Hero?
Also normalerweise müsste ich jetzt hier looten kommen, aber die sind inzwischen so besogen. Genau, der ist total ansagen. Gibt sowas wie Oversung. Kann man jemanden zu viel besingen? Dann würde ich die Kategorie an Jürgen Klopp geben. Ich nehme mal einen, der fast schon verrissen wird, vor allen Dingen hier in Deutschland. Kai Havertz. Das nervt mich langsam. Mir ist klar, das ist kein Dog. Mit dem würde ich jetzt auch nicht zwingend in die Schlacht ziehen und sagen, wenn ich in der 90. Minute noch einen Ballbesitz habe, dann mache ich alles über Kai Havertz. Das will ich damit nicht sagen. Aber alle tun so, als wäre das ein totaler Flop und so weiter. Insbesondere, wenn man sich mal das Saka-Tor jetzt anschaut vom Nothing-in-the-Forest-Spiel bei Arsenal, dann sieht man einfach nur, dass Kai Havertz den Laufweg macht. Ganz uneitel. Der zieht durch, macht damit die Räume auf. Der ist jederzeit gegen so ein tiefes Team als Neuner denkbar, weil er echt ein gutes Kopfballspiel hat, weil er für lange Bälle anspielbar ist, weil er permanent die Läufe alle macht. Er kann aber auch gegen richtig gute Defensiven, wie zum Beispiel für Eickaap gegen Liverpool, kriegt das hin, dass er die ganze Defensive beschäftigt. Er macht dann nicht die fünf Tore, die er hätte machen müssen, aber er beschäftigt sie. Der spielt Neuner, der spielt Achter, der spielt manchmal Sechser, wenn er zufallen hat. Der spielt Zehner, der macht alles für die Truppe und er macht es, finde ich, sogar ganz gut. Nur erkennt man es halt nicht immer gleich auf den ersten und manchmal auch noch nicht mal auf den zweiten Blick, sondern oft erst auf den dritten, aber er macht sie die Dinge und erzählt halt zu den Fußballern, da kann man das nicht so gut messen, was er der Mannschaft bringt. Und ich würde auch noch nicht sagen, dass der bei 100 Prozent ist von dem, was wir gedacht haben, dass er da hinbringt, aber er ist nicht bei 0 Prozent, so wie ich manchmal medial den Eindruck bekomme.
Ich habe tatsächlich die Beobachtung auch gemacht. Ich gucke ja selten noch privat in der Freizeit Fußball und das Arsenal-Spiel habe ich auch angeguckt. Und ich dachte mir, das haben eigentlich alle Leute für ein Problem mit Kai Harvards.
Ja, und ich fand es interessant zu hören, dass er auch sehr guter Neuner sein kann. Immer wenn in der Nationalelf Kai Harvards da mal gespielt hat, dann heißt es, oh, Notlösung, jetzt versuchen sie wieder hier. Mensch, wir brauchen doch den 2-Meter-Stürmer. Da scheint man unterschiedliche Perspektiven aufhören zu können.
Sein Problem wahrscheinlich, dass er überall ganz gut ist, aber keine Position hat, wo er wirklich super Durchschlagskraft hat. Wobei ich ihn auch als Spieler unwahrscheinlich gerne in meinem Team haben würde. Also ich bin auch echt ein Fanboy von ihm, aber irgendwie ist er halt überall gut. Aber nicht so, irgendwo fehlt es halt dann die paar Prozentpunkte auf einer Position, wo er sich dann wirklich herausstechen würde.
Uli, du siehst, wir haben weiter diskutiert, während du wegwachst. Ist das denn eine adäquate Einschätzung von Fabian deiner Meinung nach?
Ich finde schon, dass er als falsche Neun seine beste Position ist. Und das ist auch relativ klar so. Jetzt hat er halt aber den Vorteil, dass er anderswo hinrücken kann. Aber ich finde schon, dass es die Position gibt grundsätzlich. Ob es die im System immer gibt, ist die andere Frage. Aber von den Fähigkeiten her ist er glaube ich sogar ziemlich perfekter.
Ich glaube bei uns hat er auch ein bisschen das, ich nenne es das Mesut Özil Problem.
Ja, und du musst halt gräten und du musst auch eine gewisse physische Erscheinung haben. Also da ist ja, ich meine, jetzt im Nachhinein sagen alle, ach, Philipp Lahm und so weiter. Aber das hat ja wirklich Jahrzehnte fast schon gedauert, bis der mal akzeptiert wurde auch als Führungsspieler. Und erst als er nachher in der Champions-League-Pokal und Weltmeister-Pokal in einem Kalender ja quasi, also in einem Jahrzeitraum hochgehalten hat, dann war es so, ach ja, Philipp Lahm habe ich schon immer gesehen, dass er richtig fantastisch ist. Du willst einfach kein Lauch sein in der Erscheinung, sonst wirst du nicht anerkannt. Ja, genau, deswegen mache ich diesen Podcast und musste mich sehr an YouTube gewöhnen. Aber das ist was ganz anderes, das ist was für die YouTube-Kommentare. Fabian, wer ist dein Ansagen-Hero?
Ich habe wieder einen Trainer dabei und zwar mit Garcia Pimienta, dem Trainer von Uli Las Palmas, dem Aufsteiger. Da hatte ich schon vor ein paar Monaten mal gesprochen, dass die das ganz gut machen. Das machen sie übrigens weiterhin so. Tabelle 9. Knapp nur verloren am Wochenende gegen Real Madrid. Wir haben dort 1-0 geführt. Es sah lange Zeit danach aus, als könnten sie was holen. Und der Trainer ist ziemlich spannend, wie ich finde. Er kommt, wie gesagt, aus der Schule der Katalan, vom FC Barcelona. Er hat dort die zweite Mannschaft trainiert. Auch sehr erfolgreich. Er ist danach nach Las Palmas gegangen und wurde von Laporta, vom Präsidenten vom Hof gejagt. Da gab es Missverständnisse, Ungreiftheiten, weiß ich nicht. Irgendwie Kunden, die sich nicht so gut, die beiden. Aber der ist ein Trainer, der im Vergleich zu Xavi, wenn wir jetzt die Brücke da kurz schlagen wollen, jemand, der ein taktisches Konzept hat, der ein Spielsystem hat und der ein Team, wie ein kleines Team jetzt wie Las Palmas, ziemlich weit nach vorne bringt, offensiv spielen lässt. Und muss man sagen, wird mir im Moment noch ein bisschen zu wenig gelobt.
Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, Ding, Hat-trick! Wir haben den Las-Palmas-Hat-trick! Ich habe so sehr drauf gehofft und dann habe ich deine Nachricht gesehen und dann habe ich mir auf die Zunge gebissen, nichts zu schreiben. 14.12. MVP Kirean Rodriguez, ausgewählt von Fabian Pakulat, 16.01. Unsung Hero Alvaro Valles, der Torhüter von Las Palmas und jetzt haben wir auch den Trainer. Ich freue mich so auf den Außenverteidiger in der Nächstenkonzert. Super, ist doch schön. Las Palmas ist offenbar ein Fundus an solchen Dingen. Mario, mit was möchtest du uns überraschen?
Der Name ist jetzt, glaube ich, den hat man vielleicht schon mal gehört. Das ist Charles de Quetellare, belgischer Nationalspieler, kickt bei Atalanta Bergamo, weil er von Milan dorthin verliehen wurde. Er kam 2022 von Brügge zum AC. Knapp 37 Millionen haben gewaltig auf seine Schultern gelastet. Man spricht von sehr jungen, sensiblen Fußballspielern. Er hat viele Großchancen vergeben, hatte gute Spiele bei Milan, aber irgendwann gab es nur noch abfälliges Kopfschütteln, 40 Pflichtspiele, nur eine Torvorlage. Dann eben jetzt die Laie und bei Atalanta blühte er auf. Das freut mich für ihn wirklich sehr, weil man es ihm angesehen hat, wie er zu kämpfen hatte in Mailand. 25 Spiele wettbewerbsübergreifend, 7 Tore, 7 Vorlagen. 2 davon jetzt am Wochenende beim 2-0-Erfolg über Udinese Calcio. Das sollte einmal gewürdigt werden an dieser Stelle, dass der sich rausgekämpft hat aus seinem Loch bei Mailand. Genau wie Atalanta, Spaß macht es auf jeden Fall.
Absolut. Atalanta damit auf Rang 4 jetzt gesprungen durch so einen Lauf in den letzten Partien. Wenn wir dann schon Milan mitentwint haben, dann lass doch noch schnell deinen Moment des Spieltags abfrühstücken.
Genau, kann man sogar auch mit Udinese verbinden, nämlich vor zwei Wochen ist mal wieder in einem italienischen Stadion ein Spieler rassistisch beschimpft worden. Mike Mignard war das und jetzt am Wochenende hat Zanziro ein wirklich sehr schönes und irgendwie ergreifendes Zeichen gesetzt. Da sind überall die Lichter ausgegangen und dann wurde das Zitat von Martin Luther King eingeblendet. The darkness cannot drive out. Darkness only light can do that. Und dann sind überall die Handylichter angegangen und alle zwei Mannschaften, alle Fans, Spieler, Trainer haben applaudiert. Und ich glaube, das hat Maikman ja gut getan. Und das tut uns gut, wenn wir jede Woche wieder aufs Neue sagen, dass Rassisten keinen Platz für uns haben.
Aber absolut. Komisch, dass man es immer nochmal wieder sagen muss, aber wir tun es sehr gerne. Falls ihr dazu noch irgendwelche Fragen habt, dann hört den Beginn der Schluss – ne, nicht Schlusskonferenz, so heißt er nicht mehr – der Bundesliga-Männer-Sendung, der Analysesendung von vor zwei Wochen. Da habe ich mich auch nochmal geäußert. Fabian, was ist dein Moment des Spieltags?
Es ist ein Abschied und zwar der Abschied von der Ex-Schalker-Legende Ivan Rakitic, der den FC Sevilla verlässt.
So wird er ja immer auch in Spanien genannt, oder? Ex-Schalker-Legende.
Er ist auch Sevilla-Legende. Wahrscheinlich ist er noch mehr Sevilla-Legende als Schalker-Legende. Muss man ganz ehrlich sagen, denn er hat da glaube ich den Großteil seiner Karriere verbracht. Und er muss jetzt gehen und ich habe das Gefühl, dass er nicht ganz freiwillig gehen musste. Er geht nach Saudi-Arabien. Natürlich wird ihm das auch versüßt monetär. Aber der FC Sevilla hat auch große Probleme und auch finanzielle Probleme. Und ich glaube, der muss jetzt mehr oder weniger gehen auf seine alten Jahre. Er hat sich emotional verabschiedet auf einer Pressekonferenz. Er hat im letzten Ligaspiel nicht mehr gespielt und hat sich dann tränenreich verabschiedet. Er hat dann nochmal gesagt, er würde trotzdem seine Kinder in Sevilla bettwächen, schlafen, so ungefähr. Es war dann nicht so gesagt, aber in die Richtung geht es. Und dann waren seine Kinder zu sehen, seine Frauen, die sind alles andere als glücklich, glaube ich, über den Wechsel. Auf der anderen Seite, wie gesagt, geht es halt nach Saudi-Arabien. Da wird er jetzt für die Renten noch ein bisschen was mitnehmen. Und dann wird er vielleicht auch wieder zu Sevilla zurückkehren in eine andere Funktion. Wir werden es sehen.
Ja, als siebter oder achter Trainer vielleicht. Also für alle diejenigen, die sich gefragt haben, hat sich bei Sevilla irgendwas gebessert. Seitdem wir das letzte Mal über Sevilla gesprochen haben, die waren ja schon häufiger Thema. Nee, immer noch ganz, ganz dramatisch. Platz 16, 17 Punkte, 1 Punkt Vorsprung vor Kadis auf Rang 18. Also das ist immer noch hochpräsent bei Sevilla und jetzt dann eben ohne Ivan Raketic. Uli, du darfst jetzt den Abschluss machen. Du warst der Beginn dieser Sendung, du wirst jetzt ihr Ende sein.
Wir nehmen ja am Deadline-Day auf, das heißt vertraglich verpflichtet, dass man ohne Chelsea am Deadline-Day nicht auskommt, aber zugegebenermaßen anverwandelt. Ich mache es ganz schnell. David Nunes hat am gestrigen Mittwochabend in einem Spiel vier Mal Aluminium getroffen, das hat es so noch nicht gegeben, in der Premier League und das ist schon für sich einigermaßen zum Schmunzeln. Aber dann geht er zwei Minuten später ums Eck und macht einfach eine Vorlage dann fürs 4-1 von Luis Díaz. Das zeigt, welch grandioser Typ das ist. Und Honorable Menschen an, das ist jetzt streng genommen nicht in der Liga, aber im Pokal. Der erste Auftritt Klopps im FA Cup an der Enfield Road, das You'll Never Walk Alone und die entsprechende Reaktion da drauf, da schließt sich dann ja auch der Kreis dieser Sendung hier. Das ist schon besonders und da kann man dann auch schon nachvollziehen, warum so viele Menschen weltweit das Lied, der Verein und diese Kombination aus Lied, Verein und Trainer so bewegt.
Das ist nachvollziehbar aus meiner Sicht.
Aber absolut. Und da bist du als übertragender Sender, ich weiß nicht, ob wir da zufällig vielleicht teilnehmende Gäste hier haben, da machst du die Bäckerfausen, denkst dir, ey geil, wir durften diesen Moment haben und verbreiten. Es war wirklich ein ganz besonderer. Und wenn ihr es noch nicht gesehen habt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dann schaut es und vor allem hört es euch auf jeden Fall noch an. Ihr drei, ich danke euch sehr.
Jetzt hast du mir doch nur die Tür aufgemacht für einen weiteren Senderhinweis, weil die Franzosen heute nicht da waren. Es sind ja drei Derbys über die Ligen verteilt am Wochenende. Olympique Lyon gegen Olympique Marseille, Derby d'Italia, worüber wir gesprochen haben. Und in Madrid ist Derby auch, stimmt es, Fabian?
Richtig, das wollte ich gerade noch anfügen. Atletico Madrid, Real Madrid zum gefühlt fünften Mal in den letzten zwei Wochen.
Spielt ihr nicht so ganz rein gegeneinander?
Und die drei Derbys gibt es alle in einer Konferenz, die ich hosten darf.
Sehr gut. Jetzt sind ja wirklich alle Dinge abgefrühst. Sogar die Liga – wer hätte damit noch gedacht? Wir grüßen an alle, die mal wieder keine Zeit hatten. Aber ich bedanke mich bei euch, dass ihr Zeit hattet. Das war eine Aufnahme in vier Teilen. Wenn ihr es gemerkt habt, dann habe ich schlecht geschnitten. Ansonsten vielen, vielen Dank für eure Professionalität, für die wieder aufgenommenen Bälle. Danke an Uli Hebel, Fabian Pakulat und Mario Rieker. Danke euch drei. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke ich für die Aufmerksamkeit. Wie alles im Rasenfunk ist, auch die Ligatur von euch finanziert. Rasenfunk.de slash supporters club. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Und dort könnt ihr auch dem supporters club beitreten. Und dann könnt ihr hier nach dem Zufallsprinzip erwähnt werden. So wie das Johannes, Emmerich, Andreas, Benny, Inchka und Beite geschafft haben. Herzlichen Dank für euren Support. Und bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut und bleibt vor allem gesund. Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.